d'abord je voulais en faire je voulais
faire mon propre portage
sur une leçon de vie que moi je suis en
train de vivre en fait
donc mais pour faire un reportage il
faut des images il faut être chose donc
et je voulais que ce soit quelque chose
de réel réel de vrai je voulais pas tout
fait comme si c'était même publié des
vidéos d'un cercueil pour annoncer ta
mort à tes fans ce soir regardez
maintenant
[Musique]
alors tu as mis Kyo qu'on t'a mis que ta
femme je comprends au début que ma femme
que ta femme donc tu as des enfants j'ai
des enfants je sais donc tes enfants ils
ont cru que tu étais mort
ils n'ont jamais vraiment bien écrit
mais je l'aurais laissé plus d'un jour
de doute tu les as tu laisses aller
c'est croire commenter
plus d'un jour un peu plus d'un jour
mais ils étaient comment dans quel état
ils étaient mais ils étaient pas bien
mais je recevais de messages papa je
suis sûr que tu es pas mort pour moi
s'il te plaît autant
il y a ta fille qui a publié un message
sur facebook à la suite de l'annonce de
ta mort repose en paix papa je n'arrive
pas à y croire pourquoi la vie est si
injuste pourquoi toi tu vis encore
devenir Papou et papa tu avais encore
toute la vie devant toi je t'aime on
t'aime on ne t'oubliera jamais repose en
paix papa d'amour donc là elle y croit
très très compliqué à moitié mais voilà
alors il y a ton beau-fils qui a
d'ailleurs publié des vidéos lors de ton
de ton enterrement il était sous le choc
regardez maintenant
en fait il a fait une mise en scène de
sa mort que nous on n'était pas au
courant du tout donc on a été un peu
sous le choc en même temps forcément
donc j'espère que vous pouvez comprendre
un petit peu la situation donc ne pensez
pas que nous on avoir quoi que ce soit
dans cette histoire parce que c'est
c'est une idée de taré ce qu'il a fait
en vrai on sait tous avant comme des
Bleus
beaucoup vont penser que c'est une bague
de mauvais goût comme moi et j'y pense
toujours c'est une blague très mauvais
goût alors ton beau-fils donc penser une
blague de très mauvais goût parce qu'on
va revoir ça tu organisé tout ton
enterrement et tu es arrivé ensuite en
hélicoptère regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
un truc de ouf non
donc là tu arrives en hélico
en fait
avant d'atterrir tout le monde sait que
je suis vivant c'est parce qu'on ne voit
pas la vidéo que j'ai lancé juste avant
sur l'écran géant mais tout le monde
sait que je suis vivant avant d'atterrir
vous avez expliqué que vous aviez une
grande famille et vous n'aviez plus de
contact avec énormément de membres de
cette famille donc vous vouliez aussi
réconcilier la famille et finalement on
voit votre beau-fils qui dit bah on est
un peu blessé etc est-ce que vous avez
échoué ou est-ce que vous êtes contente
ce que vous avez fait je suis assez
convaincu de ce que j'ai fait par contre
il y avait un dixième de ma famille qui
était là
maintenant il me recontacte on est
désolé on comprend le sens de ta vidéo
maintenant
je veux plus te lâcher ça veut pas que
que tu étais si blessé à l'intérieur
donc
le sens de ta vidéo c'est que tu étais
en froid avec beaucoup de monde de ta
famille et tu as voulu quoi créer un
électrochoc on veut en simulant ta mort
on était pas au froid on n'était pas
froid donc pourquoi tu l'as fait parce
que on ne se voit pas je voulais pas
faire le premier pas
j'ai fait beaucoup dans le passé pour
plaindre et comment tu as eu l'idée tu
en as parlé à ta femme te dit je vais
faire un truc pour réunir toute la
famille je vais simuler mon ma mort
c'est ça c'est ça au début c'était hors
de question tu as dit hors de question
c'est hors de question ma femme n'a rien
fait du tout les messages que vous avez
vu qu'on pensait que c'était elle ce
n'était pas elle c'est moi qui faisait
tout de A à Z c'est ça est-ce que vous
avez pensé aussi quelques ça pourrait
avoir sur vos proches parce que quand on
apprend le décès de quelqu'un ça peut
être traumatisant même si on sait plus
tard que c'est faux surtout quand on est
enfant
ah
les enfants ils ont vraiment été cartés
de tout les enfants étaient au courant
mes petits-enfants qui vivent avec moi
donc mon fils je lui dis papa il va
faire quelque chose ne crois pas les
gens ne t'inquiète pas on l'a placé chez
ma sœur
on lui a dit voilà garde un peu
garde-nous le petit un petit peu il
aimerait bien aller chez toi sans savoir
que donc
le message de votre fille qu'elle poste
en fait c'est un fake aussi c'est un
prank c'est à dire qu'elle joue le
message que c'est le message on a vu le
message de votre fille en fait je vais
vous expliquer quand elle compatie en
fait elle aussi elle dupe les gens en
fait non non pas tout à l'heure vous
avez dit le lendemain c'est un jour en
fait ce qui s'est passé moi j'ai lancé
ma mort
puis j'ai contacté la production la
production enfin que qui m'ont filmé
pour mon reportage ils m'ont dit oh tu
es pas mort je dis non j'aimerais bien
faire un reportage est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord de me le faire ils m'ont dit
c'est un truc de deck qui est en train
de me raconter mais nous on veut bien le
faire si tes enfants sont au courant et
ta soeur
donc le lendemain donc j'ai dû mettre ma
fille au courant après et ma soeur vous
avez fait quoi à vos proches à part vos
très proches que vous étiez mort pendant
combien de temps
de moi ça deux mois combien de temps que
maintenant vous avez fait croire que
vous étiez mort de deux jours deux jours
chaque jour
c'est la production ne vous avait pas
demandé d'alerter vos enfants vous ne
l'auriez pas fait
mais je voulais laisser quand même
très dangereux parce que imaginez un
drame qu'on apprend une nouvelle comme
ça et que votre fille elle le prenne mal
et elle passe à laquelle aussi je vais
rejoindre papa on fait comment non une
blague de merde comme ça on fait comment
si votre fille a dit je vais rejoindre
moi aussi papa dans les étoiles elle ne
le croyait pas de toute façon vous
croyez pas vous et votre femme et aussi
complice qui dit oui vas-y fais comme si
tu étais mort c'est pas grave c'est quoi
ce monde en fait c'est dans quel monde
ça qu'on est mort en interne on revient
à la belle mando là comme si on est mais
c'est qu'elle monte ça c'est quand même
c'est quand même moi ça me fait flipper
pour les enfants en fait pour les
enfants pour les proches l'impact comme
il dit Guillaume la sensibilité l'impact
de dire il est mort tu vois la tombe il
y a une chanson et après non attends il
est pas mort il t'envoie tes proches ou
pas
non pas du tout il y en a aucun qui a
cru à ma mort ah ouais vraiment c'est
c'est la proportion que ça a pris sur
les réseaux avec les autres personnes
mais ma famille réellement il n'y a pas
que vous vouliez puisque la première
phrase que vous avez dit c'est pas
justement serait concilier avec ma
famille c'est je voulais être là déjà je
suis là donc en fait c'était ça la
finalité
vous êtes content d'être là donc vous
c'était aussi une des finalités c'est
faire des vues Tik Tok vidéo faire du
buzz non c'est pour me reportage aussi
en même temps ok
je donne une leçon de vie il faut aimer
les gens quand ils sont vivants il y a
personne qui vient chez moi personne je
suis vraiment seul pour ça donc je vois
même ma sœur faire des barbecues avec
tous avec tout ce que j'ai fait
auparavant ce qu'on était ensemble
j'arrive chez elle à l'improvise je
crois tout le monde moi je suis seul on
navigue jamais donc maintenant ça ma
sœur elle l'a compris ça fait déjà un
moment parce que
c'est la météo
pour qu'il comprenne que si j'étais pas
là
je suis diamant une fois je suis déjà
mort une fois ça n'a touché personne
mais tout ça
au téléphone
[Musique]
tout le monde se demande effectivement
comment les gens vont réagir il y a
jamais en meurt qu'est-ce qu'il y a des
réactions de gens qui vous ont surpris
c'est ce qu'il y en a vous avez vu ce
qu'ils ont écrit ou entendu
une fois que ça a démarré j'ai pu faire
marche arrière j'ai voulu mais c'était
trop tard j'ai vu le message des gens je
savais pas que autant que personne
tenait à moi
des gens de Tik Tok qui faisaient des
vidéos plus Rome alors je me suis dit
mais pourquoi tu as fait ça pourquoi
mais c'était trop tard c'était trop tard
d'ailleurs je m'excuse à tout le monde
d'avoir avant-goûté maintenant c'est pas
mal je regrette certaines de certaines
choses je regrette ouais regretter un
peu ouais parce que quand vous avez fait
de la peine
de faire de la pédon genre c'est ça et
là vous avez vu des gens très [__]
parce qu'ils vous aimez et que surtout
surtout que maintenant vous savez que on
me dit que mes enfants méritent de
crever pour ce non je te promets je te
promets que sur des réactions elles ont
été incroyables sur les réseaux je n'ai
que des bonnes réactions dans mes
commentaires dans mes dans mes followers
mais je vais pas regarder la critique
parce que je me suis fait mal au ventre
en zapop un petit peu les pour toi les
gens ils sont complètement tarés
pourquoi ils vous ont dit quoi c'est des
menaces de mort carrément vous méritez
de crever vous toi ta femme tes enfants
vous êtes vraiment des des grosses
merdes mais où va-t-on quoi je mérite
mes enfants n'ont rien à voir là-dedans
pas crever pour ce que j'ai fait quoi
c'était quoi la cause de votre mort en
fait j'ai fait mon canapé épisode 1 je
suis censé j'étais censé faire parce que
j'en ai déjà fait j'en ai déjà fait 3fa
un arrêt cardiaque donc on a déjà rire
vraiment de mon cœur qu'il faut vous
aviez déjà fait des arrêts cardiaques et
donc là vous avez dit ouais c'était le
gardien parce que de toute façon je vais
je crois après vos arrêt cardiaques vous
croyez que vous alliez vous rapprocher
de votre famille de vos amis en fait non
donc en fait j'ai dit ouais je suis
toujours seul
quand on est seul c'est ça vient de soi
non
de toute façon on est tous pareils
je ne vais pas dans ma famille je
pourrais y aller on y va pas et pourquoi
vous y allez pas
parce qu'on m'invite pas je veux pas
aller chez les gens et vous inviter les
gens chez vous
mais ils sont déjà pris autre part ou
quelque chose
pour trois saucisses et 4 merguez
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas j'ai voulu faire de mal à
personne j'ai fait des
erreurs je l'avoue j'ai fait des erreurs
mais
voilà ils vont regretter aujourd'hui ou
pas
certaines choses certaines choses par
contre je regrette pas d'être ici bah tu
as un amour moi je vais te dire de te
voir parce que voilà après c'est vrai
j'étais vraiment au plus bas non mais
c'est vrai est-ce que ça vous a ça vous
a cassé je n'ai pas dormi je ne mangeais
plus là vous étiez mort
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis déjà invité partout maintenant
que j'oublie pas
quand même c'est qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
va regarder ce soir l'émission et qui va
dire mais qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir
faire le fou et comme ça
c'est pour ça que vous regrettez après
il faut qu'on se voit ça vous le
regrettez parce que menacer les les
enfants
c'est pas bien de menacer les enfants ni
de menacer vous de mort et votre famille
c'est pas bien du tout mais c'est vous
qui avez été chercher ça tout seul
que vous espériez auprès de vos proches
c'est ce qu'ils ont été assez triste à
votre goût ou est-ce que vous avez été
déçu est-ce que vous avez eu la
tristesse attendue que vous vouliez dans
le regard de vos proches que vous est-ce
que vous êtes assez tristesse à votre
goût
j'ai la conviction que tu n'es pas à
mort arrête ah ouais le samedi c'était
réservé qu'à la famille le marquer sur
le d'accord je n'ai personne
qui avait été pas trop dégoûté que vous
êtes dit bon lui c'est pas vraiment un
ami que c'est le moment aussi de voir
aussi c'est les mecs qui sont vraiment
triste les amis que je possède que je je
pense avoir il n'était pas là au cœur de
trois jours ah bah tu vois je vois qui
était là qui tient à moi maintenant donc
mes amis et tu leur parles plus non
c'est fini
tu es vivante
pas de voir ses propres funérailles non
mais c'est vrai donc toi tu as tout vu
moi j'ai tout vu et tu as vu lui ouais
il est pas venu lui il est pas venu j'ai
eu des gens que à laquelle auxquels je
ne m'attendais pas ils sont venus et
vraiment les principales les principaux
n'étaient pas venus